you're on a diet or you're trying to
lose weight or get in shape one of the
best hacks for being social while being
on a diet is doing a pre-dinner or a
pregame instead of saying like oh how am
I going to make this menu work at the
sushi place with all these carbs you
just have all the protein that you need
before you go there and then all you
have to worry about is getting one tiny
dish of whatever because you already got
all your other macros hit and you saved
enough calories for that thing and that
way you go to dinner you're not like oh
I'm on a diet I can't eat because you
already hit all the main stuff that's
harder to get at a restaurant on your
own at home and save a little bit of
money too because then you don't have to
order the double steak or the double
chicken for 25 extra